foreign
oh my gosh
[Music]
we're doing it you ready Guinness
oh my gosh
we're doing it hello everyone
good morning good morning good morning
am I in focus
is that focused I think so
there we go
good morning
welcome to the right time Club
[Music]
how exciting
good morning good morning
or afternoon or evening wherever you are
around the world
welcome everyone Bobby Benavides
says good morning fam Joan morning all
Evelyn good morning Joel and ganass
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning Jerry and Morris and Bob
Kirk as we say here
what goody what's goody
oh my gosh hello everyone
this is so exciting
I just got off a call
where I booked a holiday party
I moved to holiday party for December
2nd won't he do it yes won't he Willy
amen yes
I'm going up to the Knoxville area so if
anyone
around that area
um
anyone around that area I need to scoot
back a little bit to get more in focus
[Music]
um
I'd love to make a road trip of it
if anyone else um
in that area has anything going on
maybe do another event while I'm on the
road holla at your bizoy
John mulhill good morning fam
Jerry says holiday party work yes amen
Yep they're coming in I've booked a few
so this is um this is an exciting time
of year
and we are looking for more excitement
so even if you're not in that area
if you know of um
even not you perhaps
uh if you have a friend or a family
member or someone else
doing a holiday party or such looking
for some entertainment
[Music]
good morning Bobby Bobby Sutton good
morning everybody
what good what goody these Peeps are
coming in her
y'all know the drill this is the right
tank Club
we're gonna write a joke live on the air
together today it's very exciting indeed
I know
okay asked Mr Joe
good morning Mr Joel
do you think it's safer to travel to
shows through Uber instead of driving
safer
well I mean if you have your own car
that's definitely the safer out do you
mean instead of
walking
do you think it's safer to travel to
shows through Uber instead of driving I
mean I think driving is the preferred
method
unless you don't have a car then you
could Uber
whatnot
hmm
[Music]
oh Lance Stewart what's good what's
goody fam
yes Bobby we were talking about holiday
parties I booked one and
uh in Knoxville on December 2nd
so I was seeing if peeps um
we're gonna make a run of shows if
anyone else had any events going on in
that area
in that er uh
in that era
good morning Kevin Sonny said unless
you're a drinker yes
as well you have a car but make sure
you're not a drinker yes indeed very
valid point
good morning smokey
what goody
we cooking now fam we cooking now
[Music]
we cooking now so we're about to get
into it my friends as Peeps are rolling
in
we are about to write a joke live on the
air I know it's so exciting
the word of the day is skill
and we're about to write a joke live on
the air using it but if you've already
written your joke
do post it in the live chat and I will
read it live on the air after we write a
joke live together
[Music]
oh okoya says I have a car it's a newer
model I'm a little skeptical about
pulling up in some places yeah I feel
you there yeah there are some shows in
Atlanta I will no longer do for those
reasons right there
but it's really all up to you my friend
what you feel most comfortable with
but yeah that is a part of it poor
chisel
foreign
the music has changed let's do it Jerry
said Guinness has an Afghan on the bed
nothing too good for our pets
we have two cat trees for our kitty
wife drives blankets over chairs and
gives him to give him tents
it's true
it's also that he was in my wife's
office
this Afghan so I just picked it all up
together to transport him because he's
thrilled every time I do that
he'll be all right
and we'll be all right because it's time
it's time
what's up Tracy J good to see you
we about to ride a joke live on the air
so
the word of the day is skill
and if y'all ready
let's get into it my friends officially
welcome to the right tank Club
right Tenors what goodies
word of the day is
and we are the right Ten Club
[Applause]
all right let's get into it all right
let's get into it my friends so
the word of the day is skill
we're gonna be writing a joke live on
the air together
Aura Mis Amigos aura
thank you Lance uh that intro is not new
um hot brother and Patrick Fowler
actually made it this was during the
pandemic when we were doing this live
stream every single day
look at that little quaffed of hair that
was popping down
um
uh he actually made that for us we used
to do this live every single day for 400
days and he actually made that intro for
us and I just remembered to do it
so
um thank you Lance
I'm glad you enjoyed it what's good he
say what's goody
we all out here and we are ready to
write
so
as it goes my friends the word of the
day is skill
and here we go today's word of the day
is skill so right along with us the goal
of this exercise is to write a joke
using the word of the day
today we are using the big Atlantis this
is my favorite pen of all time
the Bic Atlantis this is the pen that
started it all for my love of pins
what's today's date
the 16th
where the day is skill
so for the next 10 minutes we are going
to write a joke together using the word
skill so
feel free to ride along feel free to
um
brainstorm with me here but for the next
10 minutes the whole goal is to create a
joke and away we go in three two one
so I always like to start with
brainstorming
just what comes to mind when I hear the
word skill so just off the Jump it could
be skill saw
uh what else does skill make you think
of expertise
skill professional we're not even trying
to be funny right now we're literally
just trying to
just get ideas potential connections
potential premises just getting
stuff out of our head and onto the page
we can then start to organize into joke
form
so skill skill skill I said skill saw I
saw someone said skillet that's funny
Skillet so there's some word play that
could be done there if there's common
phrases
that can be another thing you can do
with skill
um
man of
many
skills
I believe that was
um
what you want to call it
uh but what's his name uh from Taken
wasn't that taken Liam Nielsen
Liam Nielsen in Taken I'm a man of many
skills I believe he said
um athletes says Russ yes
skill saw
skill set skill sauce also makes me
think of C saw
uh so there's something there
potentially
yet particular set of skills says Russ
very nice
um
let's see skill set
so now that we're kind of brainstorming
here now I also brainstorm
um
how to personalize this as well so for
me
um how I could personalize this is you
know I could say like
being a husband
is a skill
you know
comedy
requires
skill
um motor skill
says Lance very nice
Jerry says lack of skills
you can also think of what does skills
what can that sound like cat skills you
know the old um
back in the Disney all those old school
Comics used to perform in the cat skills
um
common requires skill
set says Eddie G yeah very nice
and I have something that popped in my
head thinking of the movie Taken is
um
when my wife met me she was taken
acquired a special set of skills or um
yeah we're brainstorming right now let's
keep going here my 80d just went a
little left there
so
[Music]
um
skill set I like skill
saw particular skill set yeah yeah so if
we want to dig a little bit deeper what
would a skill set be you know or a
require skill
also s kill
is also what skill could be I mean just
making a bunch of random connections
right now
so now as we're winding down getting
about halfway through the 10 minutes the
goal now is to start
picking a premise picking a specific
direction to take this in Jerry said
coping skills yeah that's good
something about the taken thing the
thing about making a joke about taken
though is that it requires people to get
the reference so anyone
it's kind of a specific movie it's kind
of a specific quote from the movies so
in the broader sense
it could be tough to translate
um to the stage because it requires
people knowing this specific quote from
this specific movie
um so just keep that in mind with your
own writing as you're writing jokes of
like
yeah this joke about this street name
and your home City may work but will
that travel even an hour outside of your
town you know you want to start making
material that is a little bit more
um
has more Mass Appeal than just like a
local reference
so if I were to make this a little more
you know if I were to personalize this
which is always a way to give your jokes
more Mass Appeal
a good way to do that
is um how can I personalize this so I
could go the husband route husband
requires a skill
or um comedy requires skill so I think
for this
I think what I'll do is uh you know the
husband route
um
so for the premise I think I'll do um
husband
is easy
being a husband is hard so I'm trying to
set up people to think being a husband
is easy and then the punchline is saying
that it's difficult
so what are different setups that say
being a husband is easy
um
my husband duties
require
actually I like the other way I like
that it's easy I like setting up that
it's hard and that it's easy
housing duties require a lot of skill
um
requires skill
not every
man
set
for marriage
um
skill
so so far for the setups I have my
husband duties require a lot of skill
getting married requires skill not every
man has the skill for marriage let's get
a few more setups in there that we can
then pick one to then flip because
that's the whole goal of joke writing is
you
you want to flip the Assumption you want
to create that misdirect having the
audience think in One Direction and then
the punch line creates a surprising
misdirection if you will
I know pretty fancy so as we are dialing
in on skill
set motor skill coping skills I think
there's ways we can misdirect
um the word skill so right now we're
setting up skill to mean a specific
Talent a specific expertise a specific
professionalism
that requires me a husband but it could
be something like
A coping skill we could kind of
misdirect it that way
so as we're thinking of how to do that
setup punch
could be
[Music]
um
my husband duties require a lot of skill
all right
a lock
um skill and the thing about joke
writing is at any point if you think of
a joke
is
um write that down you know we're going
through the process of writing a joke
but at any point a joke May pop in your
head
write that down you know don't resist
the urge because even as I'm thinking
it could be I'm saying me as the husband
but it could be my wife
because I was being a husband requires a
lot of skill but then what popped to my
head is my wife complains about my
husband's skills
and then it
I told her
on her coping
skills
so my wife complains about her my
husband's skills I told her to work on
her coping skills so see we're starting
to get a little misdirect going there so
in the final few seconds here how can we
tighten this up here
um
we're talking about coping which is
really like dealing
with
um
so
all right so we're Landing the plane
here
skill
set
of coping
mechanisms
so being married requires a specific
skill set
of coping mechanisms
so maybe having a happy marriage
requires skill
okay
so
oh Eddie said the only skill I needed is
to say I do oh yeah so like verbal
skills yeah yeah
Russ said now I have to cope with only
seeing my kids every other weekend oh
yeah yeah
I like that
so for this one you know it's not the
best joke but for 10 minutes I don't
hate it you know being married requires
a specific skill set
of coping and I don't think I need set
requires a specific skill
of coping so there's like a pause there
a specific skill
being married requires a specific skill
of coping so now it's like you know
coping skills not the best not the worst
so for 10 minutes you can kind of see
how we went from a single word into a
potential joke there
which I don't hate you know we're not
gonna be um breaking any world laugh
records with that that's not something
I'm going to do on stage but
for the sake of a 10 minute exercise I
am happy we at least got to
a setup punch joke structure so comment
with your joke ideas
and I'm excited to see what you come up
with here but that is the name of the
writing game my friends you're right 20
jokes and end up keeping one so this is
just one of the many jokes you could
create out of this brainstorming
exercise so have fun with it my friends
all right
ah
what's happening
there we go
cool
well there it is my friends
not terrible
not great
but not terrible
I think there's better wording there
but I'm gonna comment with mine
honestly
being married requires a specific skill
pause coping
not the worst not the best
but for 10 minutes
it do what it do shouting do what it do
shoulder
yes indeedy
so do post your jokes my friends as we
move forward here
it's Akuma good morning me Amigos ah
buenos Buenas Dias Akuma
all right so the word of the day is
skill so do post your jokes in the live
chat I'm gonna read them live on the air
my friends
we got peeps watching on YouTube we got
peeps watching our Facebook group
and our Facebook group
is where we do the live voting so if
you're not
in our Facebook group we actually post a
word of the day every single day in
there as a fun writing prompt for you
to get the juices flowing
but
all that's being said
now is the time we read your jokes live
on the air so how exciting is that huh
how exciting oh
let me just pull it up yeah
and the first joke I'm seeing
and also feel free to give each other
feedback here you know this is a
community this is a collaborative effort
so feel free
to write your own jokes
foreign
we rolling deep we got a lot of peeps in
here
so the first joke I'm seeing
uh looks to be uh Morris
what's goody Morris Morris says
I bring a unique skill to the workforce
whenever I make a joke I immediately get
fired
all right all right
I see you there fam let me turn these up
a little bit
all right there we go
all right
um next up oh yeah I don't hate that one
bring unique skill the skill is whenever
you make a joke
you get fired yeah
a comedian not being able to hold down a
job who would have thunk
[Music]
what's that one
yeah
yeah nice all right
next joke
Bobby benavidez
I don't like to consider my lack of
friends a curse it's more of a skill of
pushing people away
all right
friends a curse it's more of a skill
of pushing people away I like it yeah I
mean not I don't like that you don't
have friends unless you like that but
um
I like it you use the word my friend
well done
oh and as Bobby said we are halfway
through the finish line so don't forget
to vote Yes go vote over in our Facebook
group my friends
go for it
and um
also while you're voting
um your boy is open to be hired this
holiday season if wherever you work is
doing a holiday party or if you know of
someone doing a holiday party
that could use some stand-up comedy or a
funny MC
hola atcha bizoy
my wife greatly appreciates it so
do keep that in mind
I can do it virtually as well
but do holler at you boy for real for
real well let's let's get it going here
uh Evelyn
my boss said I needed to work on my soft
skills
so I bought a gel pen
that was loud my apologies
I can turn that down a little bit
try it again
but I like that though soft skills
that's that's a that's one we didn't
think of
brainstorming soft skills
so I bought a gel pen I love it I love
it
yeah
I don't really have anything for that
one well done there Evelyn very funny
some good silly goosery going on there
next
Juke arms Sheen
Jones
my best skill is knowing when to be
silent unfortunately my audiences have
the same skill
where's the laugh
um
I'm with it I I like that
Rob oh
Jones on a roll fam Bravo
well done there Joan very funny
next up
Bob
uh I'm a man with certain number of
skills but sadly none that will help
with
help me with relationships
help me
oh I'm Bob hmm
I think
um
let me see yeah
certain number of skills
but sadly none that will help me with a
relationship help me I wonder if there's
a way to tighten up
that punch line you know what I mean
to where it's um
a man with a certain number of skills
none of which
are dating skills
um social skills oh now that now that
we're done brainstorming now the skills
are coming to my brain
um
a man with a certain number of skills
but sadly none that will help me with
relationships
help me
I think I'm a man with a certain number
of skills
none of which are relationship
s
perhaps
and a certain number of skills but sadly
none that will help me with
relationships
something with the setup of certain
number of skills
something makes me feel like it would be
like
which certain number of dates
um
there's silly none that will help me
with relationships help me
I like it though I think it's a fun
nice self-deprecating joke I think he
used the word as well so I mean I'm with
it I'm with it there Bob no need to
overthink this
is my apologies I like it
uh smokey over on our YouTube channel
I've got skills to pay the bills now I
just need someone with skills to pay
for food and gas ah
oh I like this I wonder if um
there could be even a bigger misdirect
here because food and gas could be
considered bills
um so it could be something now I just
need someone with skills to pay my
credit cards so now
it's creating a misdirect around the
skills of paying your bills or actually
you just getting more debt in a
different way
excuse me
next joke
Smokey a song
Jerry Kroll here we go
my dad always said I only had two skills
eating all the butterscotch ice cream
and embarrassing him on purpose
I said that was totally not true I don't
like butterscotch ah aha
always said I only had two skills eating
all the butterscotch ice cream and
embarrassing him on purpose I said that
was totally not true I don't like
butterscotch nice
nice mysteric there Jerry I think it
works
I think that definitely works
next joke uh
I'm not sure who's this one is
my wife cooks with a skillet when I cook
with it it's a hack
it's a hack am I missing something
my wife cooks with a skillet when I cook
with it it's a hack then there's like a
dash did I miss
oh it's a hack it
I see
Skillet hack it is that like a hack
basically saying that you can't cook
I like that
cool beans yeah I like the word play
there well done
um Bobby Sutton I named my car Liam
Nissan because it has a particular set
of skills it's low on gas mileage and as
the salesman was quick to point out I
can fit two bodies in the trunk
ooh oh my heavenly day
that's a fun one
I like that one
Liam Nissan it's a true story as well
Liam Nissan's very funny
quick to point out I can fit two bodies
in the trunk yeah I'm a fan of that one
well done there
well done there Bobby
[Music]
that's hilarious
uh next joke
Aaron despiva I have a ton of skills
most of them don't relate to work
all right all right
ton of skills
most of them don't relate to real work I
wonder if there's another way to say it
of like
I have a ton of skills
or it's like on my resume I have a ton
of skills
mostly
at being unemployed or you know what I'm
saying I'm trying to go
I'm trying to say the same thing
you know just with less words most of
them don't relate to real work
could we I have a ton of workplace
skills mostly being unemployed or
something like that perhaps oh no
but I like the uh I like where the
premises go in there for sure
I'm not sure who's this one is
um add a front row seat at a James Bond
impersonation competition
it was A View to a skill oh boy
that's fun that's a fun one
had a front row seat at a James Bond
impersonation competition it was A View
to a skill
which is a play on that James Bond movie
title right what is it a
license to Kill
or I wonder if it would be licensed
license to skill perhaps which requires
a license to skill
being a good James Bond impersonation
requires a license to skill
license the skill I don't hate it
keep it a bean yeah I mean
oh A View to a Kill
is the name of the movie I gotcha
sorry
I didn't quite get that one I don't know
all the James Bond movies I'm sorry
oh yeah
next up
uh is it is it June is it June bag
uh my skill with combustibles resulted
in four kitchen fires Three Grill fires
two field fires and one awesome nickname
the hottest chick in town
oh
that's fun my skill with compostables
hilarious
I like that that's fun it sounds very
true as well June I gotta say that does
sound very true and fun for anyone not
in your um in your town
that's very flammable
oh how fun Jerry said there's lots of
new people again today keep coming back
gang yeah yeah yeah welcome
Welcome All To Me
[Applause]
come on back
yep we do this every Wednesday
where we get a new word and write a new
joke Together live on the air and then
you post your jokes in the live chat for
me to read
we do this every Wednesday at 10 A.M so
come on back to the right 10 Club
this is Guinness for those of you that
don't know this is my dog ganass
anybody
hey buddy
looks like princess and the P right now
um
June says it's true and how I married a
fireman oh wow
that's funny yeah yeah that's worse
that's very funny
yeah that's a funny tag to that joke
actually as well
scrolling up
where's the next one oh June's joke
zavi
having a skill is not really useful
unless you are just full of it oh nice
nice shoot Ah that's a fun that's a fun
one there Xavi having a skill is not
really useful unless you were just full
of it yeah
well done I like that one
very nice
um not sure who this one is
uh my mom told me I was funny and I
killed but it came out as you aren't
funny and lack skill
oh that's fun I like I like the um
the remix there you're hearing one thing
but she sang another
very nice
uh Lance
Stewart I thought I didn't have any
skills until I watched the Casey Anthony
documentary that's when I realized I'm a
better gardener oh my Heavens Lance
so yeah a lot of movie references or
show TV show references
uh today so yeah that would require
people to like understand who Casey
Anthony is but
um
overall I'm I'm with it there
and Lance said I could only come up with
one and it's messy I see what you did
there you silly goose
Sandy Bernstein denial is one of my
coping skills
it's visas too judging by how many times
my credit card gets done
oh it's funny
coping skills denial is one of my coping
skills and then Visa getting denied I
like that very funny well done there
Sandy well done Sandy
excuse me as I get a bit of a drink here
it's good vodka
next up I'm seeing
is
um
Robert Vick
um malevolent forces in my childhood
made it vital for me to develop a
superpower at femoral unions I had the
skill of invisibility
oh that's great
I'm good I like it Robert yeah yeah
that's funny
nicely done
um
Chris Beasley
I got a degree in Communications yep I
spent 70k developing the skill of
opening my mouth
my wife wishes I just got a GED
oh I like it I love a good marriage joke
for sure spent 70k developing my skill
of opening my mouth
my wife wishes I just got a GED
I like it
yeah yeah
it's kind of opening my mouth wife
wishes I just got a GED
well one of it could be called like or
as my wife calls it developing the skill
to opening my mouth
yeah my wife wish I got a GED yeah I
like it there's no need to overthink
this I'm sorry there Chris just trying
to think of Ora as my wife calls it but
I like that one as is so
no need to be picky Packy here
it's Akuma
I think my laziness is one of my
greatest skills it's been getting me
nowhere for a very long time and I love
it
all right all right I think my laziness
is one of my greatest skills and it's
been getting me nowhere for a very long
time and I love it
ladies and it's one of my greatest
skills it's been getting me nowhere for
a very long time yeah I don't know if
you need I love it I think it um
it could be like laziness is my greatest
skill
it gets me nowhere fast
something like that maybe I don't know I
like it though
super unique take on it on the word
skill there
Hulen
I'm not a skilled ventriloquist but I've
been told I'm the best at talking out of
my
noise yo that's funny fam
that's funny I like it but I've been
told I'm the best at talking out of my
ass yeah yeah
checks all the boxes there nicely done
there yulin
Tracy J I was blessed with the skill set
to make people laugh
then it was taken away
from me when I self-diagnosed myself as
a comedian
the laugh and it was taken away
when I self-diagnose myself as a
comedian
I was blessed with the skill to make
people laugh
so are you saying you're not funny or
you're saying you're funny when not on
stage
is that what you're saying there Tracer
J
um because there could be
foreign
people laugh
because right now it's saying you have a
skill to make people laugh but as a
comedian you don't
so it could be you maybe need to
um clarify of like
I've been blessed with the life skill
the social skill to make people laugh
but maybe you like the professional
skill of a comedian maybe there could be
some sort of word play there
[Music]
um
Cece
uh it takes a lot of skill to do as
little as possible just ask any CEO
all right all right
I see it SCC I see it as CC
but if y'all know any CEOs your boy is
booking holiday parties
yeah
yeah so holler at your boy
but for real though
anybody watching this right now
if you work at a place doing a holiday
party
or your spouses or a family member is
or you just know of one
let me know
my wife greatly appreciates it and I do
too hmm
uh Chris grullon
my mom told me I was funny and I killed
but it came out as you aren't funny and
lack skill oh I guess I read that one
earlier
nice I like that though Chris yeah
that's funny
it seems like it could be part of a
bigger bit around a lot of
miscommunication
and it could be for the sake
um your wife telling you this and then
it's just one example of many of you and
your wife
uh having miscommunications
hahaha said if lacking skills is a skill
I think I'm skillful
all right all right
congrats fam
oh I read the wrong CC one said I took
the power tools away from my husband
until he learns how to use them it's
called a skill saw not a mess up your
whole house
oh nice
very nice
um Sandra dos my strength is in hard
skills that's why I make everything
harder than it should be including
modesty oh my gosh my strength is in
hard skills
I make everything harder than it should
be uh I'll
that's great I love that
very clever there Sandra yeah not many
people want soft skills and hard skills
I need to think of that one that's very
funny
Eddie G said my wife said the only
bedroom skills I have are making the bed
very funny
uh new member Daniel Desmond well
welcome
to the right Kenny Club
I used to think I didn't have any skills
but I found out that was my skill all
right all right all right that is quite
a skill the skill that keeps on giving
nicely done there Daniel
uh
[Music]
um Victoria said my skill is not having
one okay okay
hey you're all beautiful people and have
beautiful skill sets everyone
um make sure
Annabelle
when men have the skill to give birth
only then do I think labor will be
equally divided
yeah there could be something here with
um the skill to give birth only then do
I think labor will be equally divided
there could be something about equal pay
here as well
um
yeah I like it I feel like my wife would
really like this joke as well well done
there Annabelle
oh
whoa
wasn't that a good
um a good sneeze there
so as we're Landing the plane here who
is in the lead on the votes my friends
foreign
said I get my husband to do everything
by showing him I lack skills
you got skills fam you got skills
oh my heavens
it appears
Sandy Bernstein
congratulations
congratulations there Sandy it's a great
joke denial is one of my coping skills
it's visas too judging by how many times
my credit card gets turned down
that's that's a winner for sure
and Bobby benavidez and Bobby Sutton in
second and third broth
Bravo to everyone
[Applause]
Bravo
Bravo my friends congratulations
I just realized this picture is crooked
still maybe that's all right
hello add never hurt anyone right
but congratulations Sandy that's a
winner for sure
oh and Jerry said supercharger corporate
work and book a conference for event
planners oh my gosh a conference for him
event planners
that would be incredible
what
say what that sounds incredible
foreign
look into that yeah yeah
that's a great idea there Jerry
Sandy
it's always fun my friends
but alas we must land the plane
go forth with your days my friends
I love you all
so so much I appreciate all of your time
you spend here in the hot breath verse
I love you all
y'all have a good day out there
hey bud
enjoy yourselves be safe I love you all
and as we always say here
angels on y'all
angels on y'all hot breath verse have a
good day out there
bye y'all
don't forget I'm available for booking
this holiday season
[Applause]
all right y'all have a good day out
there I love you so much
bye y'all